hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back I bet you didn't think I'd be
back but guess what I'm back and you
know what sometimes when you come back
it's better like Terminator 2. that was
definitely better that he was back I'll
be back right
I rest my case all right this week we're
talking about cmmccontrol m a DOT
l2-3.7.2 provide controls on the tools
techniques mechanisms and Personnel used
to conduct system maintenance you better
keep those evil it guys in check right
[Music]
thank you
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so on this one I have to admit uh
like some others but not most of the
others it may sound a little obvious if
you read it but let's be real here not
so obvious in practice right
you hire the it guys you hand them the
keys and whoosh
it problems are solved right that's how
it works that's the magic Inside the Box
no you see when you are into defense
Contracting you're going to have to be a
little more mature than that
it's hard for me to go there really like
it's hard for me to be mature
anyway
you need written procedures you need
documentation on your processes for
allowing access to your systems you
can't just go give them the keys because
his name's Jerry and I think he backs
the background checked not sure
uh yeah maybe past a drug screen I don't
know uh you're gonna have to justify
every step of how you run your system on
paper through written procedure and that
includes your it team who gets access to
what and how they get and how they get
that access I hope that made sense you
get the point anyway let's dive into
what the assessors are actually looking
for on this one and we'll find out how
to answer it first thing you're looking
for is determining if tools used in
conduct assessment excuse me to conduct
a system maintenance are controlled
let's try it again determinative tools
used to conduct system maintenance are
control so Implement tools are only
accessible by authorized pose users who
have been given access those tools
number two determinive techniques used
to conduct system maintenance are
controlled this is implemented tools are
only accessible by authorized privileged
users only approve tools which provide
uh with which provide approved
techniques are available so in other
words we've configured our maintenance
tools so they can only do the things
they're supposed to be able to do
third determinative mechanisms used to
conduct system maintenance are
controlled uh again if we were to sort
of give an answer here we might say like
tools are only accessible by authorized
privileged users only approved tools
which provide approved techniques are
available only approved mechanisms are
installed by approved privileged users
for use in system maintenance again all
this has got to be documented where do
we document this here's a hint and our
company we do in our it operations
policy which determines how people are
supposed to interact in our system and
what they're supposed to be doing as far
as running the it operations yes we
deliver one of those completely done for
you and customized to you if you guys
decide you want more help you want us to
work with you one-on-one so just know I
know you're like where do I even start
on this
we were there but we figured it out and
we can figure it out for you too so
determinive Personnel used to conduct
system maintenance are controlled only
authorized privileged users have access
to system maintenance tools period
so and on call we work with defense
contractors just like
you who have had this deformed nist itar
and cmmc compliance stuff dropped in
their laps like a seagull on a sunny day
but we teach you how to level up and be
a proper on-call compliance hero for
your company eliminating gaps gray areas
and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
is your secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
now that's what becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you I bet you never guess that
by the name of our company
ding
ding that will make your life so much
better like I get it you've been binging
on my content for days
and your eyelids are getting heavy I
want you to wake up tomorrow and feel
like you really accomplished something
check out our website self schedule time
with one of our amazing amazing
compliance Solutions Engineers they're
like uh Tinkerbell and Peter Pan they
just sort of like fly around the room
and then they go Boop and compliance is
solved just like that anyway if you love
the content we're playing out there for
you help us out with a big thumbs up on
that like button or even better smash
the Subscribe button for more Tinker
Bells no but hey until the next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there show us some love in
the comments below and I'll see you on
the next one
[Music]
all right